for the first time in almost two months
shelters are at a fresh fruit market in
Hubei with zero new local infections
reported in recent days the lockdown in
the epicenter of the outbreak has eased
residents can finally leave their homes
and even apply to leave the province but
health conditions are strict in Beijing
remains off-limits
Wang Shin is looking forward to
returning to work in the capital but
expects to stay in Hubei for at least
another month we can't go back to
Beijing yet there are many of us who
live and work in Beijing but Stocking
who pay for now but our health is the
priority we absolutely have to listen to
the garment of this with imported
infections now the government's main
focus Beijing is tightening restrictions
historic areas popular with overseas
visitors are heavily monitored by police
this part of Beijing is usually full of
tourists but today as you can see it's
pretty quiet and behind me a barrier has
been set up preventing non-residents
from entering these small streets
community volunteers check entry permits
and for high temperatures in the central
business district many employees have
returned to work checkpoints have been
set up at every commercial and
residential compound new arrivals to the
city are rigorously questioned airport
traffic is down 80% but roughly 8,000
people are still flying into Beijing
every day
locals were incoming travelers could
spark a second wave of infections I do
worry about these imported cases some of
my friends and colleagues returned to
China recently it's concerning but new
local cases are under control Beijing is
the political center is understandable
that is getting stricter here now all
international arrivals must be
quarantined at designated hotels for two
weeks for many in China strict measures
are a small price to pay for controlling
the outbreak Wang Shin has this advice
for those around the world affected by
virus lockdowns
don't cause trouble for your country our
countries are like parents fighting for
us we should obey the rules if we all go
out there's going to be chaotic
so stay home and follow instructions for
those in hubei an evening stroll feels
like a hard-won treat after weeks of
being forced to stay indoors nothing
seems so sweet as being able to stop and
smell the flowers Katrina you al-jazeera
Beijing